you want oh look at oh what's this what
is this hi I'm Neil Patrick Harris and
I've been asked to read questions while
playing with puppies and how do you say
no to that what's one of your weirdest
or funniest fan encounters I had an old
tiny fan once with lead is squeaky so
then I got one of the newer Dyson fans
that's better if you had to get Count
Olaf one genuine compliment what would
it be
he is devilishly handsome he has metal
you know that means not metal like your
collar but metal dumpkins what are your
plans after the third season I'm
assuming last season because it will
cover the left totally fortunate event
and when it wraps filming will you go
back to Broadway
okay that's mom that's my lace love my
shoe thank you I'd love to go back to
Broadway someday I'm looking forward to
resting series of unfortunate events is
super fun but all kinds of exhausting
much like you know when you really have
to take a dump but you you can't because
you're not outside you know that feeling
yeah
and you really got to go and then
finally going out
I need a rest hey question what's the
craziest rumor you've ever heard about
yourself and I was on Malcolm in the
Middle
in a movie about your life who would you
want to play you and David Oh answer the
question who would play me Josh Duhamel
and who would play David Nick Jonas next
question this is my favorite allowed to
pick a favorite what in your opinion was
coddled off better disguise they're all
pretty good I think I like detective
Duval the best right
he's in the bio village episodes I
neither hipster man he talks like this
everything that it says is cool good a
book oh cool is there a celebrity that
you've met that left you completely
starstruck
David Franco
easy to look at to put it bluntly Count
Olaf is a garbage human how do you get
into character to play such a despicable
person it's kind of easy as if you're
ever grumpy or wishing that you were a
jerk I get down and negative you can
just channel channel that into the
character how often do you get to play
someone that is downright awful answer
me you still talk to the Kim Miam cast
would you ever consider collaborating or
reuniting with path down the line I do
still talk with hitman down mostly Colby
solders because we have kids there
similar ages and she I'm Taryn her
husband lived in New York for a bit but
yeah we text and shoot threes I don't
think we'd have a reunite on this ship
you all right now you are a troublemaker
yes you are yes thank you
these are so cute these dogs you played
a lot of really different characters do
you have a favorite one my favorite
probably I don't know surely say no it
was fun she was a girl and I sort of got
to play her like she was in Mad Men she
talked like this it was less fun when I
had to pee because I was wearing padding
and Spanx
and it's kind of talking you know do you
appreciate when fans come up to you in
public or is it annoying no it's never
annoying I like fans when they come up I
like when people say nice things less
fun is when they just try and take your
picture while you're eating in a
restaurant that's never a good picture
I'm like talking bill if I'm scowling
something that's always fun to hear
right would you ever hook to tony's
again oh I would love to do that again
heart break Joe Teufel there's all the
performances it's the best weren't sure
to watch and it's all performances by
people who are doing shows live so then
you get the live show all around what
did you learn as a young actor in DD
Howser MD that help you later in life as
an adult actor how to suture my own
wounds
how did the neuter dogs that hasn't told
me that much what is the most memorable
moment of your life that you would like
to cherish forever Oh Len the birth of
my children holding newborn babies the
game train you that's a pretty amazing
thing kids by the way wouldn't love the
price I would be leaving with four more
dogs how can you go about choosing the
themes for your family Halloween
chocolate each year and can you hints to
some potential options for this year no
hints we have talked about it it's much
more of a negotiation now because the
kids speak the English language and have
opinions before we film in here here put
on this lion costume here you look like
Dorothy snap now it's come on boo beep
uh-huh
you're gonna do this you're gonna wear
this put it on
what do you think happened with Barney
after the show ended and what did he be
up to now
probably the same old same old what
would he be up to two fingers of scotch
and probably 15 check once you go to
karaoke going
that's a good question Rocketman good I
tend to go with Elton John songs cuz
they're fun I also know all the words
that that Devil Went Down to Georgia
yeah that was my my New Mexico rap days
he was in a pine cuz he was way behind
and you wanna make a deal when they came
across this young man song with building
a plan what's your idea of a perfect day
playing with puppies well probably a
perfect day would be with my family in
Hawaii on the beach thinking of pina
colada and riding Disney theme park
attractions I don't think this is me
being [ __ ] in Hawaii but that would be
a perfect day that's my arm
thank you out of all the villains and
Count Olaf theater troupe who is your
favorites
I got a soft spot for uh for hook-handed
man cuz he's was he's like my right hook
man last question if you were willingly
going to visit a deserted island for a
few days and it only have three things
with you what would you bring three
things on a deserted island a lighter or
a harpy one of those phones that that
you can call people to save you luxury
item that I bring I don't know a ukulele
no knowing on my cue maybe a flashlight
[Music]
okay all right those are all my
questions thank you for asking them and
thanks to all these puppies who are all
available if you want server to up one
of these they're all from the North
Shore Animal League so thanks to the
amazing people there for doing that and
come and get yourself oh wow
[Music]